Mike good evening first the house
wanting information from the son then
the house turning to an investigation of
dad the house just voted to formalize an
impeachment inquiry for President Biden
the vote 221 to 212 the house could have
been on firmer legal ground in forcing
its subpoena for Hunter Biden to appear
for a deposition today had the
impeachment inquiry already been in
place instead Hunter Biden skipped
out all we're trying to do is get the
needed people who have been blocked or
refused to cooperate to come in and
testify uh under oath before Congress
the house lacked the votes to initiate
the investigation for months but
moderates from swing districts finally
climbed on board Democrats accused their
colleagues of a fishing
Expedition I want to give James comr
some credit because after 50,000 pages
of depositions and secret hearings and
closed hearings I think if we give him
enough time he's gonna prove that Hunter
Biden is Joe Biden son Republicans say
it would be malpractice not to
investigate
further the Democrats would have a
simply turn a blind eye to mounding
evidence of a family influence pedaling
scheme that implicates the president
Democrats contend the GOP wants to
foster a counternarrative for 2024 as
former president Trump goes to trial
Democrats also allege the GOP is out for
Revenge since they impeached the former
president
twice this has never been about the
truth this is about avenging Donald
Trump this is about undermining our
democracy and influencing the 2024
election a vote to bless the
investigation is not the same as
impeaching the President also the house
just voted to condemn anti-Semitism on
campus the vote 303 to 126 with three
voting present Mike Chad program live on
Capitol Hill with the breaking news Chad
thanks very much hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else